[Music]
what up guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want and
today's segment is ask an expert and
have my friend don here who is former
special operations in the marine corps
you want to explain a little bit about
yourself and your experience yeah sure
so
um i served 12 years in the military
active duty and
a year in the reserves uh four years of
it in the beginning was in the infantry
and then uh tried out for special
operations made it then it eight years
um with them what does special ops mean
like is it like
like is there a name like the navy seals
like
is it that yeah so navy seals is the
special operations component in the navy
um and then we are the marine raiders
over the special operations component in
the marine corps how come you couldn't
cut it for delta
delta force yeah of course uh i've never
i've never
tried it could not cut it huh is that
the army though
yeah so it's the army yeah but that's
like everything right don't they take
from everybody everywhere
like the globetrotters of the military
yeah dude that's what i heard
spinning rifles actually where they
curve the bullets
no but um delts force is part of the
army but they do
allow like a few seats for the marines
to come in
what about green beret green berries is
the army are they a special team too
there's probably special operations too
so i guess when you talk about special
operations it all
is encompassed by uh like your command
component which is socom
so you have your regular military and
then all the specialized
units work under socom for operational
what are all the special operations for
the
military branches uh so the army has the
rangers
um that do like the light infantry work
they do a lot of uh direct action that's
like black hawk down right
yeah exactly um and they have delta guys
in there too but then you have
your army green berets which does a lot
of like foreign internal defense
training other militaries or
training other military or like a
militia to overthrow a government
um and then you have their delta force
which is
like the top tier direct action and all
the other intelligence that's the one he
wishes he was in that you couldn't get
he couldn't cut it no i really do oh
[ __ ] yeah that's like the elite is delta
force the elite of the emmy
yes more than nate they see you well
there's uh tiered assets in the
socom as well so you have your tier one
assets that's seal team six
and then your your delta force guys then
you have like your tier twos tier three
so most special operations you know are
like tier three so we consider them so
like your regular grim berets or regular
navy seals
marine raiders um and then your air
force pjs
the cct guys that the ones that call on
airstrikes what were you
i was a marine raider what does that
mean tier three yeah
and then so badly you are the nba you
weren't kobe in the nba
no we're the d-league man yeah
we were playing the nbas gotta say that
yeah gotta represent
if i pointed to a country in africa have
you probably been there
i have never been to africa but there
are uh marine units
in africa he asked the tricky questions
i just picked that up i'm here to throw
you i'm hearing authority does the coast
guard have one
special operations uh the coast guard is
no longer part of the military they're
part of the
what are they the post office homeland
security or something like that
do they have the elite coast guard
though like i think they do as well
yeah i heard though like although they
do seem like a funny military branch
before but
in terms of border patrol i heard like
they have some of the best snipers right
like they're able to in a helicopter
hit hit someone hit the driver through
the windshield
in the helicopter coast guard yeah they
have some of the best snipers because
of their mission if they need to guard
the border and you have like some cartel
guy driving they're supposed to be have
some of the best snipers in the business
is that true yeah i think it is but it
sounds hilarious so to say coaster
well their boat is like white with the
orange stripes or
red stripe right randy is not that cool
he looks like the salvation army it's
not cool
like he's talking about you're [ __ ]
talking about special ops it's like whoa
yeah like overthrowing governments and
[ __ ] yeah yeah how did you so when you
joined the marine corps
did you already know you were gonna try
out for special ops or
were you in the marine corps and you
thought it was supposed to be badass but
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then
you gotta elevate it like uh i always
wanted to do something more
after i joined the military um or the
marine corps and then i was like hey i
want to do something cooler than what i
was currently doing
but i didn't know what special
operations was so in the marine corps
right you guys have different jobs like
you do your boot camp
and then you choose what kind of job you
want to do
in the marine corps like what are the
jobs
um yeah like uh your admin clerk there's
uh like a cook
i want to be a cook this is a combat
cook comeback that's tight so you can
make a burger while you [ __ ]
pretty much that's the elite cook um but
yeah there's so many different jobs
everything radios you could be in pilot
instructors translators yeah wow
what would you want to be if you join
the military the one that kills people
was that the killer no because not
everybody does that right like every
like um like you're you're like a
computer guy like everyone learns how to
kill well they help to kill people in
their own way
yeah but it the the guy that's like the
uh
uh the guy that has the gun on the floor
like on the ground
sniper oh machine gun yeah yeah yeah
like ramble ramble ramble down the
humvee too
oh damn so you it's not one guy for all
of that there's a lot of killers
dude or you can chill in florida and
just [ __ ] take [ __ ] out with a drone
nah
i want to be like the foot soldier what
do you call that
infantry infantry all right you're a
warrior
i want to do that yeah infantry life's
tough though right yeah
definitely what about the medic i want
to do that too what do you want to do
kid you both
can i be the guy that goes okay my
friend needs a band-aid and then you do
that
there's i mean there's a lot of jobs
like that as well like yeah for the
army special forces um they're 18 deltas
it's their sole jobs as a shooter first
but then
they know they're pretty much like
equivalent to a pa so they do like
a physician's assistant physician
assistants yeah so they do operations in
the field when you get in shot
stop the bleeding what's crazy is i took
a like a trauma class
from a guy that was like a 20 year 18
delta so they're pretty much like
if a surgeon and a pa
and like like a green beret had a baby
that was him this guy had to deliver a
baby
because this person was raped like in
afghanistan
and he's also had to do surgeries on
dogs
because the dog had like the id in it
and he wanted to save the dog
i'm like dude these are some of the most
complicated [ __ ] ways they put a bomb
in a dog
send them and send them their way that's
so sad dog probably hit a land mine or
something
yeah it's just i'm like [ __ ] that's
something crazy what they do like they
they sold like a bomb in the stomach or
something
and they strapped it to his chest oh man
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] dude
you probably see some [ __ ] up [ __ ] huh
because like my friend
he was like a bomb tech or something in
afghanistan and he says that like
that was weird even though he was a bomb
tech like when he rolled in
like you just see dead [ __ ] people
whatever all over
the floor and i was like damn like even
though you're not the guy that's doing
the
like you the what you see is still crazy
yes those guys have
extremely tough jobs too because if
there's any bombs they gotta go
diffuse it yeah you know that's like
hurt locker right the guy's in there
yeah yeah
exactly like hurt locker yeah you've
seen all kinds of [ __ ] right
i've seen him a little bit i love it
when they do that
he likes to play [ __ ] down i can love
when they do well you know like
how they go it's a need to know basis
and [ __ ] like
in the military right like there's so
many people that have been to the
military that did special missions and
all that
what happens if you tail like if you're
a big
like like what's the worst that can even
happen
do you get in big trouble um yeah you
can lose your security clearance but
the worst things you could do is tell
something about a program that's
going on that endangers the people's
lives are
involved in that program you know so
like your friends can be involved in a
program and they
do something specifically that way
because they were trained to do it and
then if they know about that's the way
they do it then the bad guys would know
to look out
but you're just telling this hot chick
you've been at a bar you're trying to
impress her a little bit that's like
i mean you don't have to tell the secret
is you can make it wherever you want you
know well you're bad at telling fake
stories though
yeah yeah so when you're like let's say
your girlfriend is your girlfriend
ever curious about your military
experience um yeah she is
when when she when you tell her these
things does her [ __ ] get wet
or is she just like i don't care it's
always way around
listening yeah um no but to be honest
like the secret squirrel stuff i we
don't i mean
there's a lot of secret stuff but it's
more about the tactics and the
techniques on how you do
specific things that are classified so
what happens like you know how some
people write a book after they leave
certain things like
you're done with the military right i'm
done so if you started talking
would you still get in trouble yes so um
certain programs have an expiration date
um
but most of it's like 50 years or
something like that before it expires
what happens you could go to jail you
could definitely go to jail do you ever
answer
certain questions with that's classified
you could talk around it yeah but yeah
if you talk classified but what if you
be you don't say like i gotta kill you
if i told you
no but guys that say like that like you
know they probably don't really know or
but you've met those guys though yeah
there's a lot of guys that do
i have to like fake valor or whatever it
is for sure
yeah we we met one too and then i was
convinced
because i don't know [ __ ] about the
military and then my other buddy who's
like an
engineer in the army he doesn't even
like he's not even an
infantry guy he shoots amazingly well
and all this and i'm like hey isn't it
funny you guys are both in the military
and you can't even shoot and he's like
not even what you do like a special guy
and then
i was like roasting his ass and later i
found out it's because he wasn't
military he just lied
oh damn he was saying like he was some
special unit guy
and i'm like wow tell me more so special
they can't tell you right
yeah basically it was so special that
like
like they didn't even like it's like mi7
you know yeah i love it
yeah or like am i whatever it's like
it's off the books
and i was like damn that's tight today's
episode is brought to you
by fields okay so check this out
i had no idea i was living life with so
much
panic and anxiety it's not always
identifiable like it's not easy
when you're going through it right but i
always like had trouble sleeping and all
this stuff
yeah and um i noticed it's usually
because i'm doing like
extreme sports or whatever and i don't
know how to like calm down
yeah dude and i'm just there in bed and
i'm like man i can't go to sleep
i'm counting jumps like i can't count
sheep man i don't know what's happening
probably jacked off already yeah
nothing works absolutely nothing until
shout outs to fields for sending me
their cbd
because i do have a nighttime routine
now and i've been using it for quite
some time
and it's kind of like this whole
chill-out routine where like yo
i'm gonna go and do snowboarding i'm
gonna do whatever and at the end of the
night
i take a few drops i actually meditate i
relax
and then i have this unwind thing that i
do and now i sleep like a baby
yeah so feels is actually really easy to
take you just put a few drops underneath
your tongue
and it helps reduce stress anxiety and
for you sleeplessness
and what's really cool is like
everyone's tolerance is different right
so you can experiment if you really want
to relax and chill
or just a little bit it's all up to you
and what's really cool is that it's a
membership so once you sign up
it comes every single month and also if
you're new to cbd
you don't know who to ask or whatever
what's really cool is they have
real human support you can be like yo
i don't know nothing about this but i
need some help so that's
that's a pretty cool option they have it
is good to have support so feels has me
feeling my best
every single day and it can help you too
i know it does for me so
become a member today by going to
feels.com
off the record you'll get 50 off your
first order
with free shipping that's f e a
l s dot com slash off the record and you
get 50
automatically taken off your first order
plus free
shipping fuels.com off the record
damn dude so what do you do when you
find one of those guys that are like you
lie sack of [ __ ] i mean a lot of people
in
the veteran community do like probably
blow them up but that's probably not
necessary
to like do all that they're probably
going through some of my own struggles
and just lying about [ __ ] to impress
some people or impress themselves or
tell some fake reality themselves but
the veteran community is not
very forgiving of that like if they find
out they'll
blast them i've seen something that
happened oh yeah they're like a gang
dude the stolen valor shit's pretty
crazy yeah you mean blast doesn't like
that or you mean like like put them on
blast put them on black
oh okay okay i was like dang i thought
they were gonna kill them a lot of these
it's been happening a lot in the special
operations community
like a lot of people are claiming
they've done something these guys
would go and find their dd2 or dd2149214
and then put it on instagram what does
that mean dd214
dd214 is like a document that you get
when you get out of the military pretty
much summarizes your
military career the awards you got um
the schools you've been to so it tells
you that your metaphor is like
everything so what if you never even
went you don't have one of those right
yeah you don't you don't have one yet
right but if someone was to [ __ ]
it's kind of like
let's say they were like uh like
like they went but they weren't special
ops and maybe they were a cook at an
army
so then that's the kind of stolen valor
that that exists is they are
military but they're lying about what
branch or whatever
yeah so like for one example i'm not
going to say his name because he's
probably had enough [ __ ] array but
um he was a navy seabee which is like uh
like a construction worker yeah they
built a whole bunch of stuff but he said
he was a navy eod like one of your
friends
um but on his record all it says is he's
only been through basic training he's
been through construction school or
whatever it is but
on other podcasts would he go on then he
would talk about like getting shot in
the back
blacking out and just all kinds of
staple gun or nail gun maybe yeah but i
just
buy a welding machine oh i was brick
he was a navy engineer and he was never
like a seal
yeah damn what do you guys think of the
air force you guys think those guys are
[ __ ] i think they have the best life
that's for sure yeah my whole family's
like air force well except for my
grandfather
because he told everyone don't go in the
[ __ ] marines because you won't cut it
credit to you no not to me i wasn't i
was never going in
but to like to my dad and to my uncles
he was just like
you don't want to deal with it your
grandpa yeah his his uh grandpa was like
a colonel oh [ __ ] yeah dude he's the
[ __ ] real [ __ ] deal dude you got
you want to know some [ __ ] was uh he a
pilot he was
uh no he used to he was a mechanic so he
would help fix the planes and [ __ ] you
could be a lieutenant colonel as a
plane fixer well he probably wasn't the
one actually fixing
probably like command of all yeah yeah
yeah he's pretty sick though yeah yeah
so you should sit up a little straighter
on me
[Laughter]
yeah that's right that's exactly right
oh my god so when you were
in the infantry um like what was because
to me that stuff's already hard what was
like some of the hardest things
that you had to do uh like even in
training
and what was and then what made you go
oh that's it and you want to like push
the boundaries
um i think is the mission set for sure
like what we're doing um
in the infantry you're pretty reactive
even though the units try not to be so
like if you're
in iraq or something like that like
you'll react to
getting shot at you'll react to driving
over a bomb you'll react most of the
time instead of being proactive and like
actively going out
so you're getting punched in the face
first before you punch back and then
that's the part of it you didn't like it
yeah and so it's like if they bomb us
then we go after them like that yeah
oh what so there's no movements of like
we're gonna blast the [ __ ] out of these
fools i mean
i mean like you have a mission you like
have some bad guys that you're looking
for but
you don't have enough assets you don't
have enough guys you don't have enough
things to support you to to get there
and like that
sentence like if you just went in with
your life
or it's just like intelligence
capabilities to find the right guy to go
to the right spot
you know instead of just driving around
driving over bombs and
shooting back when we get shot yeah yeah
but special operation is completely
different you know you have
all the assets in the world to find this
guy from whatever intelligence
collections
you have to getting bombs dropped on
them for sure did the rules of
engagement change
constantly where you're like what the
[ __ ] is this new rule today oh yeah
every theater every everywhere you go
for sure
what's a theater oh theater is a place
of
where you're deployed to pretty much or
your area of operation like you might be
in the jungle
of like some other country or you might
be in a desert in the middle east or
like something like that yeah exactly
and they call it a theater because
there's so many things that play like
air land sea like
yeah exactly why damn yeah you guys got
this right you don't even talk to me
no your story so like okay cause he's
really downplaying himself
so uh your infantry and then
how did you get into like the marine uh
combat water survival school and he
started teaching
combat water and then this one jumps out
of airplanes and [ __ ]
just like a really humble guy that's
really talking about have you ever done
a halo drop i have not done a halogen
well you guys
were both in the marines right so like
put it into normal person perspective
like i'm gonna ask all
right to me military's military right
but obviously there's like
such a huge difference within the
military
of what you guys do because it's its own
like campus
basically right like so like what you
did
and then you look up to him and you're
just like oh my god you did that like
what does that what how can you like
compare that to the
to the rest of us so even with like the
the marine corps water combat survival
right
like he would be like every year you
have to do annual
swim test physical fitness test shooting
whatever that kind of stuff
he's the guy that would run the courses
uh
for like in the water you know like all
the times you go to hawaii and always
drown david in the pool like check this
[ __ ] out
it's because i've got it done for people
like him okay right so you like you you
try to get class four
class three class two class one or
what's above that
i don't even know anymore i think it
changed did it yeah
but there's like different classes and
depending on how well you swim
it opens up doors for other things where
i like to go to jump school like you
have to have was this one class one
or above or something i think so it's
been a long time yeah
so exactly yes yes so it's pretty much
like you're building up your resume in
the military and then as you build it up
you can
open up more doors to do more [ __ ] right
and then so
for him uh even for like that kind of
stuff i saw what this school
like one of them one of the things you
have to do is swim um
was like 50 meters or 100 meters
underwater 50. 50. so even that shit's
tough we have to swim the long way of
the pool
or the short way back and forth
underneath water with just one breath
so like stuff like that like how how was
that like and what made you want to go
into that and was there
uh ever a point where you like wanted to
quit and not finish the school
um for the water school yeah um
yeah i hated the water for a little bit
you're such a good ass swimmer you
taught me how to swim
i mean not i mean now but were you a
good swimmer before
school um i was i worked at the pool
before i went to that
course so i had some time to train yeah
but before that i just
swam whatever program the marine corps
puts you through and then before that my
mom like when i was a child my mom put
me through
some classes so i wouldn't drown um
pretty much but yeah that was it
um is there a special ops version of
hell week or like like the training
that's for buds right like that's for
the navy for regular military you have
boot camp
and then you go into your job school
whatever that is well we call it mos a
military
occupational skill so whatever you
choose after boot camp supply
infantry whatever you go to that
specific training and then you start
working
in the military right and then but then
once you want to specialize
is there another boot camp uh not
another boot camp a whole bunch of
follow-on schools so like the water
survival school is one
um if you want to be a sniper that's
another school if you want to
do other jobs there's a whole i mean all
the other jobs are out there as well but
for
special operations in the marine corps
you got to go through
a selection period so they send you to
now it's like six weeks long they send
you to
north carolina and you go through a
portion there and then you go to like an
unknown location and then
they do some training there to test you
pretty much like [ __ ] top gun shoes
so like
no i'm more like uh gi jane jane she's
like an
auditioning process almost so it's like
an auditioning process
to even see if you qualify for the
school that's correct and is that part
[ __ ] hard as [ __ ]
it's pretty hard yeah um what's like
some hard [ __ ] yeah what are they
getting
to do um a lot of it is a lot of land
navigation so ours and the army special
operations
one is pretty structured the same so a
lot of land navigation you're walking
everywhere with a 45 pound
pack a lot of team events how many miles
a day you think you're covering
a [ __ ] ton probably more than 20.
every day oh [ __ ] it depends how lost
you get though because so it's really up
to
oh so if you're good and you're not lost
it's probably not
20 every day but still probably give
your bad directions though you're
probably pretty funny
probably wouldn't make it so you know
how like in college right
you have an idea of where you want to go
what you want to major in
and then like you have a job fair and
then there's recruiters like you want to
join us
like is there something like that in the
military where you're like i kind of
want to do delta force but i'm kind of
on the fence between
seal and whatever like do you know of
these jobs
before you go toward your direction
i think now people have so much more
access to information that people
kind of know what they want to do now
but when i was in the military i didn't
know what
um marine raiders are where marshall was
until
i just wanted to get out of the infantry
so so for you it was like
what's the next [ __ ] and they're like
raiders all right [ __ ] it that's what
i'm gonna do
yeah oh so all right like or now
with all the information with the green
parades and all this information out
online
people have options but the military
didn't tell you
like this is where you can go this is
where the next level is
they definitely didn't and a lot of the
marine units back then were like
always like oh if we have you and you're
a good dude they want to keep you right
because it's going to help them out to
do their mission
instead of pushing you up to kind of
hold you back
cause they'd rather have you on their
team that's what happened to me as a bus
boy
he's too good we can't waste another
good one
and then i it took me forever to be a
waiter uh
so when did when you went to the marines
were you guys there at the same time or
like
no i think there's some overlap right i
got on an 0-9
oh yeah i went in and oh six okay yeah
so you could have been maybe so i was
so i went in an 03 and at that time like
um so how it works it's like whatever
positions are missing
in the marine corps they'll send those
jobs out
like to the recruiters yeah and then
those recruiters those recruiters will
get those
jobs tied out to like your your ship out
date
and so when you're like dumb like me and
i didn't even i just knew i wanted to be
a marine i didn't know anything about
marine corps
they go when do you want to go to boot
camp and i'm like uh
august then they go well here's your
four jobs you could choose from
not knowing i could have waited a month
and get another job or you know it's
just like
they didn't tell you [ __ ] they don't
tell you anything what job did you have
uh i was
supply admin um for
this unit called third anglico and it
was like a pretty cool unit so i'm like
oh i'll do that
and because then the one before that was
like a field radio
operator and then i've seen enough
movies where it's like
the guys guys always get shot yeah yeah
yeah nobody answers nobody ever answers
like i'm cool with that i'm cool with
that and i think the one
after that was a motor t which you just
work on cars
so i was like i guess i'll just choose
that one then
and um yeah but now nowadays like when i
talk to some of the kids these days it's
a way different process some people
they know they want to go like special
operations and they'll secure
almost like the whole pipeline contract
there's better counselors now
they're way better they'll secure that
contract before they even go
in so now it's just up to them to pass
where they can uh just to pass each step
but they have that job for sure
whereas i think maybe in his position it
was like you're here
and you're excellent then you try out to
see if there's even
jobs so it's like it's a much harder
process oh have you ever shot a net at a
guy
like a question though questions right
yeah i tried few dogs
shot dogs yeah damn why'd you have to
shoot a dog
they're coming at you they're coming at
you and they probably have rabies and
you know they're not like pet dogs yeah
good doggy
no they're stray dogs the stray dogs and
you don't want them to
give your mission away you know oh cause
you're like hiding in the bushes or
something yeah i mean
you shoot the dog people are now do they
have net guns
is that classical i think they do no i'm
probably sure like out of a shotgun you
could put it like a net yeah you [ __ ]
packing that in there
like batman like poof and then it wraps
up
[ __ ] wraps up yeah what about the
thing when you pull it out and you know
when it didn't travel you know the bolo
thing yeah
you throw around the legs
[Music]
what kind of [ __ ] they're having you
guys do i don't know man but not cool
enough dude yeah damn dude
next time we'll get a delta force guy
can we get a delta force guys
[Music]
[Music]
you